[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
[Music]
his exploits are legendary what he has
to teach you may very well mean the
difference between life and death your
reputation precedes you after admit I
wasn't expecting an invitation back
they're called orders
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking
today's exercise is dogfighting
two-person what hey you've got to be
kidding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after 34 years Tom Cruise returns as
maverick this is a competition film
about family friendship and sacrifice
it's a love letter to aviation we're
gonna show you what it's really like to
be a Top Gun you just can't create this
kind of experience unless you shoot it
live in order for us to accomplish this
we have the greatest fighter pilots in
the world working with us we're working
with a brand new camera system that
allows us to put six IMAX quality
cameras inside the cockpit with the
actors it's amazing what we see in the
cockpit and when an audience is going to
experience
the great magician
thanks to Tom all the actors becoming
accustomed to the g-forces by all the
training that they're doing here it is
aggressive
you can't act that the distortion in the
face they're pulling seven half eight
sheets that's 1,600 pounds of I'm so
proud of them than what they've done and
it is heavy-duty putting us up in these
jets it's very serious that's why
everybody thought it would be impossible
and I think when Tom here is that
something is impossible or it can't be
done that's when he gets to work
flying while these fighter jets is an
absolute thrill right we want to make
sure that the audience has the same
experience
Aviation film like this has never been
done in Cheshire I will never be done
again
30-plus years of service combat medals
citations only man to shoot down three
enemy planes in last 40 years that you
can't get a promotion won't retire
despite your best efforts he refused to
die
[Music]
you should be at least a two-star
admiral by now yet here you are captain
what is that it's one of life's
mysteries sir
[Music]
the end is inevitable maverick that kind
of said it for extinction
maybe so sorry but not today
you